This is the traditional protest of Catalonia's Independence supporters.
They are furious with the Spanish cabinet deciding to suspend the region's autonomy...
...and impose direct rule from Madrid.
Catalonia's decade-long drive towards independence...
...has relied on the power of peaceful public protests.
But it's met total resistance from Madrid and the European Union,...
...which doesn't want to encourage other separatist movements in France, Italy and Belgium.
An important aspect is identity, recognition of national identity.
A second important element is economy.
Catalonia is a relatively rich region and would like to raise the taxes...
...and to get its own share in its wealth.
There are seven and a half million Catalans who comprise a sixth of Spain's population.
Overall, Catalonia generates nearly a fifth of Spain's annual income.
But Barcelona claims that of every tax dollar levied by Madrid,...
...only 63 cents is reinvested in Catalonia.
In particular, the shortfall has negatively impacted the region's infrastructure.
The Catalan institutions had been asking for a long time for a new arrangement,...
...a new constitutional arrangement allowing Catalonia to be recognized as a nation,...
...allowing Catalonia to have a new financial system,...
...and to get more powers in the international sphere.
The Catalan government should show to the world that Catalonia wants to be a country...
...and wants to be a partner to the other European countries.